all right the other day i took to
twitter the boys were like this to note
that hillary clinton had failed to
include queen elizabeth in this new book
she wrote about gutsy women
well that didn't sit well apparently
with the former secretary of state and
failed presidential candidate who took
time out of her very busy schedule to
respond
tweeting thanks for getting the word out
about gutsy laura
a book now turned apple tv plus
docuseries it was a challenge to narrow
down who to feature because it's true
there are just too many amazing women in
the world
well i don't disagree mrs clinton and
maybe maybe i was being unfair to
hillary guys i
i mean why include women like queen
elizabeth or mother now saint teresa
globally recognized for their tireless
service to others
well there are so many more deserving
gutsy gals out there
just look at two who are featured on
hillary's tv series like the foul mouth
comedienne amy schumer
or megan the wap stalion whose gutsiness
is on display when she tells young girls
to shake their butts and spread their
legs
but maybe i don't know we should have
seen this coming because her co-pilot
and this effort daughter chelsea clinton
offered an early shot at yours truly
last week
we don't we don't think that any woman
should just shut up and sing or shut up
and play sports
i'm glad they read my book well if
that's the criteria well women who are
outspoken
i'm surprised that kathleen willey
juanita broderick and paula jones
weren't included in the book
maybe they'll make it to the second
edition hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else